diese turbine ist gerade der zankapfel
im streit um die gaslieferungen zwischen
russland und deutschland so wichtig dass
bundeskanzler olaf scholz heute morgen
selbst ins werk von siemens nach mülheim
an der ruhr gereist ist hier sitzt die
turbine seit wochen fest generalüberholt
und startklar dabei soll sie eigentlich
in der ostsee pipeline nord stream 1 zum
einsatz kommen es ist gewissermaßen klar
und einfach die turbine ist da sie kann
geliefert werden es muss nur jemand
sagen ich möchte sie haben dann ist sie
ganz schnell da russland hat die
gaslieferungen über nord stream 1
zurückgefahren und 20 prozent weniger
geliefert der grund dafür sei die
fehlende turbine so der russische
energiekonzern gazprom es mangele auch
an zwei papieren
aus unserer sicht sind alle papiere
zollpapiere transport wäre so weit wie
es vorbereiten können vorbereitet alle
vorgebrachten technischen gründe sind
nicht auf einer faktenbasis
nachvollziehbar und das glaube ich
gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu altkanzler
gerhard schröder und vertrauter putins
mischt sich in die debatte ein für ihn
gäbe es eine einfache lösung erklärt er
im stern interview die pipeline nord
stream zwei in betrieb nehmen sie ist
fertig wenn es wirklich eng wird gibt es
diese pipeline und mit beiden nord
stream-pipeline es gebe es kein
versorgungsproblem für die deutsche
industrie und die deutschen haushalte es
gibt genügend kapazitäten beim austrian
1 da ist überhaupt keinen mangel an
möglichkeiten alle verträge die russland
geschlossen hat für ganz europa mit
hilfe dieser pipeline und der auch noch
im betrieb befindlichen ukraine pipeline
zu erfüllen für die opposition ist der
schweiz auftritt spiegelfechterei der
bundeskanzler zieht erkennen wir eine
große show ab ich erwarte von ihm dass
er probleme löst dass er dafür sorgt
dass die turbine dorthin kommt wo sie
hingehört und das sehr schnell wieder
mehr gas nach deutschland kommt der
streit um die turbine geht weiter die
lieferungen mit gas nach deutschland
bleiben wohl weiterhin auf sparflamme
soweit also der stand die turbine ist
bereit aber russland kümmere sich nicht
so die erklärung von bundeskanzler
scholz für begann ist unsere
korrespondentin in moskau schönen guten
tag was sagt denn moskau zu der turbine
warum liegt die angeblich so wichtige
turbine quasi in mülheim ungenutzt um
ja wenig überraschend schiebt moskau die
schuld dafür natürlich nach deutschland
genauer gesagt zu siemens energy gazprom
beharrte darauf dass für den
weitertransport der turbine nach
russland noch wichtige dokumente fehlen
würden und möglicherweise beharrt es so
auf diesen dokumenten weil darin
schriftlich festgehalten würde unter
welchen umständen ausnahmen von den
sanktionen möglich sind das wäre dann
ein präzedenzfall auf den moskauer
vielleicht in ähnlich gelagerten fällen
in der zukunft zurückgreifen könnte denn
insgesamt ist es so dass eigentlich seit
beginn dieses turbinen strahls dieser
fall hier als beleg dafür genommen wird
zu zeigen dass diese westlichen
sanktionen die gegen russland verhängt
wurden nach dem russischen einmarsch in
die ukraine dass diese sanktionen eben
schlecht durchdacht gewesen sein und vor
allem im westen selber schaden würden
dass deutschland und kanada bereit waren
ausnahmen von den sanktionen zum für die
turbine das wird hier einerseits
natürlich als schwäche dargestellt und
gesehen es weckt wohl aber auch die
hoffnung dass die sanktionen womöglich
auch an anderen stellen aufgeweicht
werden könnten wenn russland nur genug
druck aufbauen kann für begann mit ihren
einschätzungen live aus moskau auf
vielen dank